hosianna und frohe kunde liebe freunde
man hat unser aller weihnachtsfest
genehmigt ja wir kriegen zu weihnachten
jetzt doch ein weihnachten am mittwoch
verkündet von der neuauflage der
heiligen drei könige melchior merkel
kaspar söder und walter müller ihr
geschenk an uns bürger vom 23 dezember
bis zum ersten januar dürfen sich
theoretisch jeden tag bis zu zehn
menschen aus zehn haushalten treffen
tierischer stress oder virologen hoffen
jetzt dass sich das corona virus in der
woche dann freiwillig ein bisschen
zurück hält weil es ist ja weihnachten
und an weihnachten sagt unsere groko ist
jedes familienmitglied natürlich gleich
wertvoll
wir machen keine regeln die am ende
bedeuten onkel carl kann ich mit zum
weihnachtsfest kommen weil wir jetzt
nicht leute in die verdrückungen bringen
wollten zu sagen dass irgendwie onkel
karl jetzt nicht mit weihnachten feiern
kann
das gros onkel karl jetzt garantiert
nicht an weihnachten mit am tisch sitzen
darf wer zum henker ist dieser onkel
gaal
warum muss der unbedingt kommen und was
ist mit tante hedwig bis zum 20 dezember
dürfen sich übrigens nur zwei leute aus
fünf haushalten treffen oder andersrum
egal kann eh keiner kontrollieren
ernsthaft wer soll ihnen der adventszeit
kontrollieren was hinter haustüren
vorgeht also außer der dicke spanner
natürlich der immer durch unseren kamin
krieg klar
corona detektiv ihrem nikolaus bis
weihnachten obergrenze fünf leute nur
kinder unter 14 zählen nicht mit was
macht eine familie mit vier älteren
kindern eines davon im wald aussetzen
und nochmal wer ist onkel karl p vor
quarantäne sehr wichtiger die etwas also
ausgedehnte weihnachtszeit verlängerung
der weihnachtsferien dass man diesen
raum hat es richtig und nicht so viel
shoppen das ist sozusagen das geschenk
müssen wir selbst sein bitte karl
lauterbach ist das geschenk da hätte ich
lieber eine holzeisenbahn sieben stunden
hat merkels hinterzimmer runde getagt
und am ende gab es wenig neues außer
empfehlung und appelle ab incidents 200
ist man als gemeinde jetzt ganz
offiziell super hot spot herzlichen
glückwunsch
was dann aber konkret passiert in so
einem super duper spot entscheiden
einzelne landräte im politischen berlin
macht sich offenbar eine gewisse
ratlosigkeit breit und die kanzlerin
wirkt ja fast müde weiß die frau
überhaupt noch was die jungs ist in
ihrem land gelang dass langenfeld liegt
vor direkt neben düsseldorf direkt neben
düsseldorf a ha und dieses wunstorf wo
sie sind wo ist das dagegen wo wohnen
sie
wo liegt denn bopfingen wenn sie mir das
noch mal sagen wo ist in ratingen ok
schön die worte rating und schön im
selben satz mal was anderes
ich fordere von berlin wohl ich das
eigentlich
statt um fiktive obergrenzen für
privathaushalte
kümmert euch lieber um sachen die
politik regeln kann um viel mehr antigen
schnelltest zum beispiel warum hat man
die verbilligten fb2 masken nicht längst
an die risikogruppen verteilt gestern
auch thema im bundestag
und da kam es dank wirklich hellwacher
phoenix regie zu meinem persönlichen
lieblings bildschnitt des jahres letzte
woche habe ich meine 91 jahre alte oma
besucht in einer einrichtung und
natürlich wurde auch alles geachtet max
gab stand anmelden musste man sich
besser kann man es nicht machen
die könnte man doch heiligabend neben
onkel karl setzen
als idee ja was für einen weihnachten
wird das meine damen und herren
armin laschet hat sich da vielleicht
einen hauch zu apokalyptisch ausgedrückt
uns allen droht sagte er
das härteste weihnachten der
nachkriegszeit naja eher mittel gute
formulierung vom aachener hobbit hier
demnächst im zdf
ihr dachtet heiligabend 45 war hart
vergesst es hier kommt einmal in die
kirche gehen
oh mein gott kein endloses krippenspiel
im kindergarten
ach du scheiße keine sechs stunden auf
der a3 um vom café mit den eltern zum
kaffee mit den schwiegereltern zu fahren
stattdessen einfach nur gemütlich zu
hause sitzen und netflix gruppen
es wird der absolute weihnachten 2020
die durch die hölle gehen
das wird so derartig ich freue mich
drauf so und dann ist ja auch schon
silvester silvester kann ebenfalls mit
bis zu zehn personen legal gefeiert
werden ja ob das so richtig klug ist
darüber können wir dann ja im januar
nachdenken wenn der richtige lockdown
kommt meine theorie man hat hier schon
ein wenig dem druck der straße
nachgegeben
oder wie kommen die neuen maßnahmen da
so an jetzt wollen sie da noch mehr
machen hier noch wenige leute treffen
irgendwann sitzt du nur noch zu hause
und vergammelte was spricht dagegen zu
hause vergammeln freundchen außerdem
silvester kann ja fast wie gewohnt
stattfinden
sogar das böllerverbot ist vom tisch
seit dieser woche also abgesehen von
bestimmten öffentlichen plätzen klar
unsere notaufnahmen hätten in kurve
zeiten eigentlich auch ohne upfinger
genug zu tun aber deswegen immer gleich
alles verbieten ich sage selbst beim
thema böllern ruhig mal die andere seite
hören deutschland deine branchen heute
die pyrotechnische industrie schön oder
und das hätte man uns um ein haar
weggenommen nur wegen corona
aber wer kommt denn da das ist ja bum
sie unser lustiges maskottchen
was sagst du darum sie wir machen jedes
silvester 130 millionen umsatz
warum höre ich das nie im fernsehen da
laufen immer nur die schlechten sachen
klar ist jedes jahr landen
deutschlandweit tausende mit
verbrennungen in den notaufnahmen
hinzu kommen knochenbrüche sowie einige
wenige amputationen eben gehört auch zur
wahrheit ohne brüllerei während hunderte
deutsche handchirurgen arbeitslos plus
die ganzen glasaugen hersteller schon
die alten germanen haben krach böse
geister vertrieben
für die germanen von heute dass der
dollar sogar ein männlichkeit symbol in
der balz betroffene weibchen anzulocken
die spd die spaßbremsen partei
deutschlands wollte uns alle
zu nehmen umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus
warum nur silvesterböllern möller
denn so viel mehr man kann zum beispiel
sein smoothie damit zu bereiten
ganz ohne strom oder morgens habe ich
seine liebste weg liebe zuschauer
er hat in diesen schweren zeiten gilt
jeder bürger hilft machen sie mit bei
unserer aktion brot für die böller
industrie proben sie und ich sagen danke
wurden sie mal was ganz anderes deine
leute die es ja was über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]